what was the lowest point in your career
I'm probably ought to say this but I
don't care my penis was in Billboard
magazine all right this is young bored
you're watching you Neil it--and I'm
glad to interview myself hello may i
alright um I'm good man good to see ya
you look a bit tired we had a bit of a
mental light night last night but you'd
know that she rolled in my hair but
would you like it under I'm gagging
thank you so much to wet my whistle me
anyway let's start with a question first
question if you shush we were on death
row what would be your last meal
probably a Sunday dinner but my mom
would have to cook it so I could have it
with my mom okay
Johnny is because I was oh yeah that's a
role that I'm what meat would you have
on you Sunday dinner I'm probably Paul
their roast chicken we Yorkshire PUD
analysis you know that's probably wrong
that's probably not Italian at all so
who has been your biggest inspiration
who has been you now I'm joking I'm
joking you're an idiot
wimon so mean I mean my biggest
inspiration over like gave it Boeing
really just because I just loved how
himself and what would you be favorite
Bowie song I mean it's obvious as hell
but probably heroes mom really make sure
I live forever
pardon the Oasis pond I love that song
too thanks you want to live forever
without signing too much of its wha what
was the moment you realize that you were
famous I just kind of still don't
realize that it's been a bit weird like
when I walk down the street now and so I
was like hello darling like hey nice to
me what's your name
what I was walking home so but asking
the question that's why when was the
first time someone approached you in the
street
about a year ago I think but then in the
UK it's been so weird cause I've been at
state so long we came home and then we
walked down the road and people just
like waving at me and like I would
approach you the street that mean Oh
hiya what was your career high point so
far I am probably ready to leave this
weekend man that mean so much to me like
I went to Leeds as a kid do oh now what
was the lowest point of your career and
the lowest point of my career
interesting question I probably ought to
say this but I don't care my penis was
in Billboard magazine can you tell us
more about that absolutely not
yeah we don't talk about the penis now
who would you most want to collaborate
with dead or alive and dead or alive Wow
we were almost on the Freddie Mercury
god I'd love to the flight part of it
Freddie is the best showman for a man
that's ever lived if you could only
listen to one album for the rest of your
miserable life Wow what would it be
probably what's the story morning glory
by Oasis twist my own twist me on how so
because it's amazing it's an base in
boxer from stone called bangers huh who
is the nicest celebrity of ever met and
why did you like them nice a celebrity
I've ever met Dave Grohl why was he nice
I just think because he makes an effort
to genuinely understand young people and
what they're thinking about even if you
might not necessarily agree with us what
was the first thing you ever bought with
a paycheck for a being a musician and
chips no I'm joking
probably the guitar it was a it was a
1964 b25 acoustic to me that wanker
wanker now what is the most expensive
piece of clothing you own Wow dumb why
are you trying to make make us look like
a wanker probably her leather jacket it
costs me four thousand pounds really
just dropped is in it in here and
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you